all right folks we're here to talk flash
god this looks crooked like a [ __ ]
Batman 66 shoot we're here to talk flash
flash season 3 episode 7 airs tonight
and there are the good folks at greg
berlanti x' company and the CW let me
direct an episode I did one last year
and so now I got to do another one this
year so season 2 I had an episode the
end of toward the end of last season
called the runaway dinosaur and then the
this season now you can see up my nose
this season I've directed an episode
entitled killer frost guess what that's
about
man we buried the lead on that one hard
to be honest though it's entitled killer
frost but there's a there's a lot I'm
gonna keep my language clean for the
four kids
The CW kids tuning in right now but
there is try to keep it clean no
promises there is a metric a ton of of
stuff going on in tonight's episode man
lots and lots it's not just Caitlin be
becoming killer frost or does she
Caitlin frost as we kind of call her in
this episode a lot but boy you're gonna
cease avatar in action remember the end
of last episode you know he's got buried
clutched up in the in Alchemy's lair and
I'm
savat are the god of speed and then they
went like you know credits and [ __ ] you
know I want to see more you're gonna see
more tonight and I can't even take
credit for that folks first off it takes
a village to make something as cool as
the flash every week and we've had
wonderful writers including edge of
Christ burg on this episode and and
Andrew you know if you know this world
Andrew knows his stuff man he wrote one
of my favorite episodes of all time of
the flash season finale of flash season
1 so I love Andrews the guy that got me
into this we added my fat man I'm Batman
and he was the guy that my agent called
to be like hitman Kevin
[ __ ] Smith Kevin Smith but Selena
likes these things would you ever let
him direct one and he was like who's
Kevin Smith no he said the guy from
Dogma yeah and boom I got to direct one
last season now I get to do in this
season so Andrew with
out him I've got a no killer frost
action in this episode he was big hand
in this begin on the unscrew who else
man the the good folks at flash from a
brain trust Bob Crippen the ad he placed
Tetris with the schedule you have no
idea how important getting the schedule
right is on something where you have a
limited amount of time on features you
know you go crazy
if you don't finish your work you can
finish it tomorrow episodic TV you got
to finish that work that day because you
got more work coming the next day so Bob
Crippen our first ad balances all that
stuff incredibly well so that I could
sit there and play with the kids not fun
who else Lexi LaRouche who is the script
supervisor knows more about this show
than anyone I think involved you know
she drives the script she gets direct an
episode this season episode 19 Lexi gets
the direct Tyler Haran who is the
production designer and also should be a
bruiser on the show he knows so much
about this world anytime you see a
visual attention to detail you're like
hey that looks like you know the hidden
oh a sign Owen ring son the Green
Lantern's symbol on a set or something
like that that's Tyler he loves this
stuff and then of course Kim without Kim
miles the eyes of the show man he
creates the look of it and whatnot I get
a lot of credit for that
so these cats I want to give them thanks
thanks to CW folks thanks to the
Berlanti folks for letting me come play
big thanks to the cast man grant like
carries this entire show on his shoulder
very both of them shoulders to plural
and doesn't incredibly well and usually
like these kids are handed pages like
days before they shoot it and sometimes
you're thrown out like say this do this
man they just take it and run like pros
Candace
Tom are on fire in this episode Keenan's
got some stuff to do is you'll see who
else and I'm saving of course the one
for last everyone's going to say it
saying it loaves Carlos is wonderful in
this episode Jesse I get to work with
everybody in this episode and they get
to show off other acting chops but it's
called killer frost for a reason this
episode
Danielle gets to sword so you'll see all
that so now I'm gonna dive into your
questions and see what you guys
no I think that's how this thing goes
otherwise I'll just keep talking to
myself alright man you fire away and
I'll ask do you like your job says
Carina Cold's its jack
am I getting that right Carina I bet you
do it's great yeah yeah I had let me
tell you I had I used to work as a
busboy
here are the jobs that I've had in life
I was a busboy at long johns tiny hands
tiny Trump like Ansari noticed that let
me see I was then I went to convenience
stores a busboy to a couple restaurants
long johns not the brain not the chain
long johns but his long johns and you
know what you don't want to hear about
this anyway I love my job it's fantastic
all the jobs I've had in this life make
him pretend for a living that's funks
think about it that's we used to do his
kid make pretend and then when you grow
up people like put away childish things
unless you're in this world where people
like will give you money make it rain so
you make pretend getting paid to do
something you would do anyway that's the
secret to life folks so I love this job
very much ok let's dive into let me see
Tony Burt says is tom felton alchemy no
tom Felton is not alchemy if anything
he's Draco Malfoy no uh tom is you're
gonna tune in tonight's episode and see
from the trailers teasers people have
been like and then in the episode
breakdown they're going like hey man I
think Tom or Julian on the show Mike but
Caitlyn takes him for a very specific
reason that has nothing to do with that
and has one of the funnest scenes and in
the episode you see a little bit and in
the trailer I think we're boom flash
like knocks out Tom somebody tweeted a
flash fan tweeted a real nice side by
side of of Tom getting punched as draco
malfoy by Hermione Granger and then Tom
getting punched by flash from our
trailer
I love [ __ ] like that so thank you uh in
any event Tom this question was as Tom
alchemy tune in and watch dude come on
ok let's see are you excited that your
episode of the flash is before the four
night crossover event next week yes we
should be talking about and we will talk
about killer frost but let's talk about
next week's round of
shows man heroes vs. aliens when we were
wrapping up my episode of flash the
script for the crossover was coming in
and so I was able to peek at it over
Lexi's shoulder I was like tell me what
goes on and what goes on is dope so I
look forward to watching that like crazy
somebody was like don't you wish your
director that no that seemed complicated
very complicated a lot of suits running
around I would have liked to have been
there to take selfies I'll tell you that
much man that would have been like
clickbait heaven and stuff but as for
shouldering that responsibility
leave it to my betters that's for damn
sure speaking of betters man anyone
watch Supergirl last night
Glen winter crushed that episode was
wonderful man it was just packed they
got a lot done in 42 minutes 41 40 to be
exact like that's a lot of show unpack
that episode and watch a million things
happen the same thing with Flash tonight
we have so many things going on in
killer frost it's crazy
Moses what they're good at over at those
shows man they pack their stories
there's multiple storylines going on if
you don't like one storyline
wait a second another one's about to
start okay Wesley Johnston asks are you
wanting to get all 4 DC series under
your belt well it's a big belt Wes let's
be honest I could fit a lot I can fit
all 4 CW series and about 8 networks
under this belt the belt that I wear
around this prodigious gut however I
love I'm just glad I got to do anything
so I've done two flashes I've done a
Supergirl hopefully I get to come back
and do another Supergirl I would love to
go over to legends of course man and and
as I said last season I'd love to go to
arrow particularly if they had let me
write an episode where I could bring my
character or co-write or whatever with
my character onomatopoeia the guy makes
noises mr.xu she in in the comics that'd
be fantastic
so I've let that be known many times oh
my god I'd love to do an arrow and
crickets so you know I don't care man
anybody that's just like come play I
like to complain these are shows that I
actually adore love flash and Supergirl
so it's very easy to go play in that
world I'm a big Legends fan as well so
it'd be easy to dive into that world but
the arrow thing you know his personal
connects I wrote the comics years
so hopefully one day man maybe Gotham -
although that's not Berlin Seavers
Riverdale Sun that's the next one man
I've seen little pieces and whatnot
Riverdale it's Archie as if it took
place in like twin peaks' sick man I
can't wait that I want to direct that's
a high school show okay so let's see
Erik Watts a stood Muse make it into
this episode Jason Mewes no he was in my
runaway dinosaur episode of course
that's my mom's car
he had that that moment and he like I
told him later in the episode I snuck
him in he was one of the villains and in
the in the police department at the end
when zooms like whose world is this and
they're all like our world are well I
snuck Jason in there he's wearing a mask
you could find him he's the only one
doing a Jersey fist pump while he does
his dialogue but when I went to talk to
him about that it's a dude you know we
had already shot the sequence where he
was coming in out of the big belly
burger what uh see I've got some
arrow training already he was coming out
the big belly burger and and and then
the zombie girder rips the door off and
of his car of the Humvee Hummer if you
will and Jay was like that's my mom's
car we shot that scene and then I was
like I want to get in back in the
episode so I won't over talk to him
about like dude I won't put you in that
other scene at the end make you super
villain so I go over to and I was like
you know what dude I think I could find
one more way to put you back in the show
and he goes you're bringing my character
back already excellent man I want to be
in this show one more time then I'll be
my guy over on arrow then it'll be my
god legends and he kept going he was
building a multi Berlanti verse episode
arc for that one character where
presumably he would show up you know on
every CW show and be like that's my
mom's car you know and then out he goes
so uh no sadly Jason didn't come back
for this episode but I brought another
friend with me man like so far each time
they let me bring somebody that one I
even try to bring Jay that was Andrews
at the ng Kreisberg
he was like do you think your friend
would want to do this I was like do I
think he'd want to do this surprise he
hasn't come into this office and
normally I tell a very dirty story in
any event yeah so Andrews ID
was to bring in to bring in Jason I came
to credit for that when I did my second
episode of flash there was an open role
for for a police detective and so a
friend of mine Ralph Garman I do
Hollywood babble-on with he he was the
guy oh my god Ralph would love this
because he watches all these shows but
he was working on Kevin and bina does
the morning show in Los Angeles on
k-rock and one of the two Kevin or bean
were off so Ralph had to stay and so he
couldn't come play up in Vancouver so I
turned to another friend of mine a dude
who you know as my co-host on geeking
out red grunberg grunty himself man who
you've seen in the force awakens snap
Wexley who you know from heroes Matt
Parkman who you know from lost the guy
who crashed the plane he was the pilot
he used to be on alias Felicity and
stuff like that so
grannies in this episode I got to bring
him along so so I didn't get to bring
Jay I got to bring Greg Grunberg
and then on the Supergirl episode I just
directed I got to bring my kid Harley's
in it as well there's a script called
for I didn't say put her in script
called for like a 17 year old kid I was
like oh my god I literally have a 17
year old kid of my own that I own and so
she got to be in the episode was just
huge she loves the show you've never
seen so much crying like I cried when I
was doing Supergirl it's an emotional
guy and I love the show but my kid like
she was dragged off that set with her
fingernails in the in the dirt man Jon
she loved being there and so so Jay
doesn't show up but grunty does show up
in tonight's episode of the flash killer
frost man what I love is if you I've
seen the TV spots because the version
that I worked on and cut I didn't see
any special effects man Big Ups go to
Arman for this Arman our special-effects
wizard he's the guy that built King
shark and Grodd and stuff anytime you
see Barry run fast that's Arman and his
effects crew he's directed episodes
Arman when I did my first episode of
runaway dinosaur last season not a lot
of effects going on not a lot of running
or anything like that so there wasn't a
bunch of special effects work it was
mostly an episode of people talking to
each other but holy heavens my new
episode of the flash is the one that
airs tonight killer frost on the CW a
lot of special effects a lot of runnin a
lot of
powers being manifested and stuff like
that so Armen had a lot to do on this
episode and he has a lot to do any
Supergirl that I just finished as well
so having worked closely with these
folks I've always loved their work in
the show it was King shark that brought
me into the CW world into the Berlanti
universe Muse was begging me for a long
time to watch the show he's like you got
to watch a hair oh man is amazing and
he'd show me clips he's always carries
around an iPad and there's a clip of
he's a look at this and Stephen of
Melanie's like doing a Salmon Ladder
you know shirtless oh it's connected I
said that's very cool was I have to do
with green arrow he goes oh you want to
see him shoot a bow and arrow and he
shows me a clip of Stephen Amell
shooting a bow and arrow and arrow and
he was shirtless and I was like you know
I think you like this show for reasons
you don't even understand yet
look South I told him so he was trying
to get me into these shows early early
on and I was like no way
and even when flash showed up I was like
gnats all right man I watched the flash
in the 90s live-action job watch this
[ __ ] now there's a flash not even
knowing that he's in the shows well so I
ducked it for like a full season of
Flash until the King shark episode when
I saw like King shark a picture of a
music called me up he's a king sharks on
flash I saw a picture king shark I was
like I can't believe they went for King
shark I thought this show is like
critically acclaimed I think I got balls
of steel to do King shark I got to try
it
it is like the Smuckers you know the
name like Smuckers better be good I was
like if they're doing king shark this
thing's got to be amazing and I fell in
love with the show and that's because
the Armin's king shark man looked
fantastic
so Armin's got a lot of special effects
going on killer frost every time
Danielle pulls her hands up like she's
doing it you know this kind of crap and
I kept sewing bigger man make it even
bigger go against your instincts and
like dig it up cuz we wanted to look
like you know like a splash page on the
book and in the comic of killer frost
Armand like saved our asses I got
Danielle keep going bigger and bigger
I'm like Danielle first it's like this
and it's like you know she's doing like
the Scarlet Witch and [ __ ] not even the
one from the movies although Connor she
wasn't like ma'am in a minute but just
the one from the comics big arms and and
and so Armin saved our ass man big Armin
himself and his crew he put this cold
smoke around her every time her hand
go up then surrounds her it looks so
metal dude it looks like something out
of a comic book
so like Arman's job on the show the
effects guy like anytime you see
something on that show we look cool and
it looks like a panel from a comical a
splash page like a double splash page
that's our man he's the splat and his
crew I don't want to take any credit
wait for me but Arman and folks who work
for him Armand are me these cats man
like they're to splash page of all these
shows so that I saw some splash page
moments in the trailer so I was like
look what they did with the cold smoke
or steam I don't know what you call it
when it's cold but oh boy it looks
fantastic I don't even know for that
answer the question if that was a
question I was answering but Armen man
he brought he brought this episode to
life let's see what do you think of the
flash doing sabotage asks Holly Anderson
I think it's amazing man like I hurt
Mark Waid who created or brought savitur
into the comics created the character if
you will for flash like was touched by
it as well could you imagine some
character like you got to fill 12 issues
of comic book I'm sorry I don't do coke
I'm just I'm I blew my nose right before
we went and it's all voiced could you
imagine like you have to do 12 issues of
a comic book every year in your out a
book for a couple years men you're just
like and and your hero is a guy that
runs fast you're just like all right
let's try this let's try this let's try
this and sabotage was a cool character
but one of many that Mark created and
now boom on the show he's this season's
big bed and I know I've seen where it's
going because I got inside dope inside
info on the show so I know where it all
heads and it is thrilling like it is
season one incredibly strong wait till
you see what's avatar can do and you see
a little bit in my episode right away
like art we come in off the tail end of
the previous episode that I think JJ
directed not JJ Abrams stunt J dude and
he's holding up Barry's you know
sabotage holding up Barry goes I'm
sabotage the god of speed we come in hot
right off of that and continue what
happens so that's why I was talking
about Arman Arman created this whole
sabotage
sequence with with flash that happens
like at the top of my episode where we
shot some plates for it plates are like
open shot shots with no people in them
like that
they'll put people in later with visual
effects so sometimes you know if you're
shooting in the real world you'll do a
movement with the camera and you'll
shoot something as if it's there and
pull it into focus even though it's not
there and then the special effects
people will create that thing later on
so we provided plates to Arman and then
Arman provided what you're gonna see is
sabot are like being amazingly badass so
big props to him let's see give away no
I can't do that
since you mahalia coming says since
you've seen some clues what's to come
have you seen how involved iris is
widths avatar and the alchemy plot yes I
have I know there are a bunch of people
always out there's like we want Irish to
have agency she's got a lot of agency
this season particularly as it comes to
that episode they all do
but iris has a standout moment Candace's
wonderful actors we all know this but
she has a you know her role chiefly in
the day-to-day adventures is to be
Berry's spine and heart and soul you
know Barry could be the hero but
sometimes somebody needs to be the hero
for Barry so they have a scene tonight
and setting the speed lab with low
lighting and stuff one of the prettiest
things I think I've ever been involved
with shooting and one of the sweetest
performances man like I can't say enough
about this sequence it is in the scene
it's so sweet and touching and they're
so wonderful with one another grant and
Candice it's it's it you will be very
very happy with that as for how she
plays into this avatar thing I've seen
it and as an iris fan you're gonna be
happy I don't want spoil anything I like
and one day I want to come back if you
spoil too much Kraft they're like shut
your mouth fat boy and you don't get to
come back so I want to come back let's
see
juror Jeremy Edwards asked would you
direct the flash movie of course I
direct yes I was gonna say direct
anything they give me that's not true
but like if somebody was like you want
to the flash movie absolutely but I
honestly would this be my first response
oh you want the flash movie while
directed I said
I'd say absolutely but I think you
should try 10 Miller first or I'd say
the shower skis I'd list a bunch of
other people who I think would make a
brilliant flash movie but as we talked
about in recent episode fat man I'm
bettin and Mark Barnard and said Tim
Miller I said that's the name dude get
the man who did Deadshot to do flash
like Tim Miller's visual genius
we thought we all saw Deadpool that
opening sequence alone is fantastic
Deadpool is wisecracker flash as played
by Azra Miller in these movies sounds
like he's gonna be the wisecracker this
is a match made in heaven so I think
they should be then and plus what who
for DC Warner Bros to take one away from
from Marvel so to speak even though it's
not Marvel Marvel but Fox Marvel but
still man like that's match made in
heaven
I hope Tim Miller for president of
directing the flash movie that has lost
a couple flash directors but yes would I
absolutely like if Tim Miller was like
man I hate the flash then be like F Tim
Miller I'll do it you know but they
should give it to somebody who who sees
things visually and I don't I see words
big fat words okay Brend Bryden Macready
says how can Barry only cease avatar
that at the end of last episode we saw
the flash was going do you see that and
everybody else is like no I don't know I
don't know why I picked a
question/answer I'm not the writer of
the show sadly or happily man to be
honest with you because I don't know if
I could write as well as these cuts to a
structured and as much information as
much like thrill I'd have like 20 page
scenes where like Barry and I are sit
around talk to each other about you know
like watching stranger things you know
nobody wants to see that so you know I'm
not I can't say what's gonna happen with
that in the future but there's a little
bit of that in my episode as well today
tonight killer frost episode we answer
that we don't answer that question but
we start to answer that question I
should say teasing you into tonight's
episode
okay Ryan Holland says Kevin will you
adopt me no we only do rescue dogs
around this place sir
but if I could I would
I've adopted you just like that we'd sit
around and watch flash together just
probably smoke okay let me see
grodd's so scary like King Kong says
Josh Josh will shirt not really question
but I would absolutely agree and I know
I've heard some things about rod rods
rods coming back this season I think I
think can't say that for sure but I
think I've heard things okay any
favorite arrowverse character asks Erik
Jordan you know I mean I got a little
partial Thea by virtue of the fact that
she's based on Mia Dearden which is a
character that I created for my run on
on green arrow back in the day and you
know that so I met her two khonshu super
sweet and that you know naturally I
played a little part in that character
so I feel partial there okay let's see
Ron Suskind
what is the guy that plays wells like
Tom Cavanagh is a genius he's wonderful
actors we've seen look at season 1 he
plays like two parts in season three
ones a playing like three different
parts at one point he plays four
different versions of wells and one
scene from last year in this season you
get to see him closer to who he is in
real life I would not say that tom is
like HR on the show but of all the
versions of wells that you've seen over
three seasons of flash HR is closest to
Tom's personalities constantly joking on
set he's an absolute livewire keeps
everybody energized and he's always
cracking jokes and stuff like that right
up to the take you could do in a very
serious take and he's cracking jokes and
then they'll say action and he goes like
total actor serious so just a wonderful
actor he's got a podcast it was a Mike
and Tom eat snacks it's called
but a great Canadian you know but man oh
man I love him he's fantastic if you get
to hang with him in real life it's it's
a true treasure but good listeners
podcast we want to hear what he's like
in real life
listen to his podcast okay let's see
would I direct an episode of Young
Justice ask skin I mean I me I
would I bought a cartoon I don't know
how to direct animation I don't think
you know but you know if they did a
live-action yeah
anyone in suits dude in costumes put a
mask on these fools
I've directed I would direct an episode
of like Days of Our Lives is that still
on right I know the young and the
restless' Dylan I directed an episode of
The Young and the Restless if they were
like they're all wiring masks and capes
I'd be like count me in I like doing
this costume stuff costume drama try to
that's how I try to pass it off
respectively people like what have you
been up to
I said well yoga hosers which is out
today on iTunes and right now you can go
watch it or after I'm done as you get
ready for killer frost tonight for on
blu-ray signed at Jay and Silent Bob's
secret stash I said but other than that
well I've been directing costume dramas
like period costume dramas and I was
like hey man I don't get that personal
they're just costume dramas to me okay
let's see
JJ bass is just direct the flash movie
JJ as if I have any say say JJ they need
to say that stuff over there
a lot of people online be like come on
dude don't be a dick direct flash the
movie like kids I have no control over
that
you know what I'm saying like that's not
like I don't call up hello mr. Hollywood
these are the films that I would like to
direct like you know they picked those
assignments and stuff and there are
better people equipped for that job than
I I'm very comfy right now in the world
of flash you know on CW and I think I'm
might have an aptitude for not saying
I'm good at it I think I have an
aptitude for that world because you get
to tell stories longer you know they get
to pull the taffy because they have 23
episodes of season so you're getting the
character stuff whereas in a movie you
got you know two hours think we gotta go
and we got to show you stuff that looks
[ __ ] amazing and stuff then sometimes
character fall and story or fall by the
wayside not on these CW shows man not on
these Berlanti shows we're telling you
man it's like this is where I like to be
feels comfy for me like you get to do a
bit of like dramatic acting you get to
do some funny stuff some humor you get
to do some action II stuff Arman makes
people run fine
asked and beat each other up so I'm
liking it right where I am okay let's
see Thomas day wants to know who'd win a
fight
Jame user macaulay culkin and I think he
spelled macaulay culkin way wrong which
we call a Cogan we talking about because
if it's home alone here in macaulay
culkin he beat two guys Daniel Stern and
and you know Joe Pesci Joe Pesci we all
saw all of a tough-ass he was in there
Scorsese movies so yeah I don't know I
think I'd give it to if it was home
alone Macaulay Culkin Nicole can takes
muse if it's if it's current-day
Macaulay Culkin versus musem uses an old
man Macaulay might take him okay Anthony
Llano asks did you put any frozen
references in your episode come on sir
kind of hack comedian do you think I am
yes of course we did the whole episode
is called killer frost at one point look
for the end joke I'm not gonna spoil it
here but look for the hidden in joke
not even an NGO look for the hidden
reference look for the frozen joke there
you go
when we when Caitlin takes Julianne
Alpert hostage is fast and you gotta
look close blink and you'll miss it it's
an establishing shot of the frozen food
place but when you see it you'll know
that we were thinking about you from
that exact question okay Martin Joya
says who is better flash or Batman
well this flash I like grant gustin's
flash you know he's had more time to to
play the character and this characters
had more time to get deeper into your
heart like think about it the work that
they've done on Barry Allen the
character over the last like 10 years
alone has really made that character
even more viable than it ever was we
always like Barry Allen the character
design looks beautiful and hey runs fast
he's a good guy and he sacrificed
himself in crisis for all of us but
between Geoff Johns and what these cats
have done over on the Berlanti universe
with this this character like you know
it's he's they've given him a rich
Baxter and he's got a very colorful
rogues gallery so I'd say equal footing
with Batman
at this point particularly this
iteration of the flash okay looking for
questions
Chris savior's did you like the season
of Constantine
I've yet to watch it but the 1i sucks
there was like a crossover thing I I
enjoyed it very much a Setsuko that did
was pretty genius okay let's see are we
gonna see well we see Jane salad Bob on
the big screen and something new yeah
they're in moose jaw's this movie we're
making I made tusks it was about guy to
his another guy into a walrus yoga
hosers out today on iTunes I'm at on
home video two girls fighting little
Canadian not the Nazis made of sausage
called broth seized and now the third
movie in that TrueNorth trilogy is going
to be moose jaws which is jaws but with
a moose instead of shark so Jane saw Bob
feature prominently in that they kind of
played the captain Quint character two
guys moose hunters from America so for
the first time and now it's been a long
time let's see we did Jane son Bob and
clerks 2 was the last time that was 2006
oh wow for the first time in a decade
Jay and Silent Bob back in a movie I
can't say well it'll be on the big
screen some of my movies lately
they don't seem big-screen bound but I
think we'll be able to get that one in
theatres okay let's see or Mallrats the
series if it gets picked up fingers
cross okay let's see what directing
challenge makes you most uncomfortable
Jonathan Gendron asks action any time
actions involved because that's I'm not
very good at it and stuff but thanks to
these shows thanks to doing the second
episode of flash tonight's killer frost
only on the CW and the Supergirl episode
I just did I've become a lot more
comfortable with a practice you just
need practice and most of the stuff that
I write and direct for myself doesn't
require a lot of special effects like
even yoga others which out today on
iTunes and blu-ray has a lot of special
play a little little versions of myself
not myself but the character I play
broth sees a bunch of them all that the
girls keep killing over and over to
teenage girls killing phallic objects
with sticks you ain't gotta be Freud to
figure this movie out but but you know
there's a little bit in there
I leaned on my buddy Andy McHale first
who are co-host education podcast with
to do the effects so I always keep it as
comfortable and as easy as possible for
me and they don't do that on flesh
they're not like never mind your comfort
we got a show to make dude not up and be
the director you could be and so that's
my scary than my scary places
green-screen action but now I'm starting
to understand a lot more thanks to folks
like Arman man because all you have to
do is provide them with an empty frame
Arman will get in there and give you
what you want you tell him you're like I
want so avatar run real fast with flash
he does it I want king shark he does it
I want Grodd he does it like so you know
lean on the folks don't see you don't
have to know everything I'd never do as
the director in fact you read the
critics they'll tell you I don't know
[ __ ] but lean on the folks that know
what they're doing man they'll they'll
get you through so don't be scared I
guess is the point I'm starting to put
my fears away okay will Jada Mason says
will you ever bring an impulse from
young justice into the show I have no
call in any of this I don't write the
show just directed two episodes now
killer frost being the second one airing
tonight so but if we could bring in Bart
Allen oh my god I'd love that if they
could I'd love it they'll probably do it
without me trust me they'll get there
let's see
buckaroo when asks Bob Richardson
writing it as we speak
Bob that's right Amazon and MGM teaming
up to make buckaroo banzai a series on
Amazon and I'm writing the pilot right
now almost finished and I love it and
I'll be honest with you doing these
shows episodic flash Supergirl has
really helped break the process down for
me in a way where I'm like huh I think I
might be able to do a good job
I'm not going to direct all the episodes
I'm bringing a lot of director friends
who also like buckaroo banzai direct the
episodes and I'll be writing a bunch of
the episodes and pilot being one of them
right now so it's going well man but
like I'm glad I've done these two gigs
three gigs two flashes and one Supergirl
because it's good training for you know
heading toward buckaroo
no matter where you go there
you are okay let's see you have free
room and food if you want says Davy Davy
James Herbert I feel like I jumped into
the middle of that conversation without
knowing what it is but free food you got
my heart what's your favorite flash
episode asks harmony a pen wizard kids
harmony my favorite episode of the flash
it should be my own runaway dinosaur but
still remains season one of season
finale fantastic when Barry races back
in time to save his mom and sees another
version of himself which just goes no
and so he doesn't get to save her and
instead he you know gets to talk to her
before she passes one of the greatest
hours of television ever produced that
sequence in the beginning alone with Tom
Cavanagh as eobard thawne explaining
everything that's gone before and
everything that's about to happen ah is
Magic like that I love that episode and
of course it contains Tom going now run
Barry run which is like one of my
favorite lines of all time we stole that
and reused it a bunch and runaway
dinosaur and then Tom did it fairly
recently when Jesse quick got her
superpowers got her speed became a
speedster I he said run Jesse run like
so that's my favorite episode and that's
why I loved runaway dinosaur because it
was like a spiritual sequel to that
episode tied in very much with it but
what I love about this killer frost
episode is that it plays like a thriller
like I never really get to make
thrillers I mean red-state kind of
counts but this played like you know
when I read it I was like let's aim for
three days of the Condor which you know
it's not a spy episode at all but like
the tenseness the the tension level of
like someone on the run that's that's
what I was kind of aiming for if you're
gonna steal steal from the greats okay
what else we got going on here
deeper odd when Leon dennis's would you
sell your version of the flash Jersey on
your site any time soon
no but yes not not I can't sell examine
on the flash logo
stuff but we're we're opening a site
soon working because a lot of people
like the jerseys that I wear and the
crests that I wear and there have been a
lot of requests like dude where can I
get that but we've done some t-shirts
and some of them but we're gonna start
making them so people could buy the
crests or buy full Jersey or whatnot
we've done some of them already if you
go to Jay and Silent Bob dot-com you can
find a fat man one and some of the other
ones but we're gonna start doing them
all me and Jeff Quigley God designs him
Jim I'll sit in the guy that puts my
jersey crest together for me and stuff
so uh look for that soon okay Craig
Tompkins says I hope we see the Kid
Flash what tonight you see something I'm
not saying you're gonna see Kid Flash
but you see something all right let me
see got to turn this episode of flash on
when I come home from work says Andrew
Grimes
that's absolutely right set your DVRs
folks tonight
killer frost the coming of killer frost
which sounds way dirtier than I meant it
is gonna happen man Joel David Martinez
asked what are your thoughts on the
flashpoint episode I loved it I thought
it's actually one of my top five
favorite episodes of the show ever was
the seasons season premiere the
flashpoint episode you know granted like
other people were like oh man I wish
they'd done the flashpoint from the
comics well they can't but I like what
they've done with this flashpoint it
sets up the entire season and wait until
you see where it goes I know where it's
going you're gonna you're gonna love
like they're gonna have their own
identity now it's flashpoint you know
instead of people just go mow flashpoint
we know that is that's the Jeff Jon
story in the comics now flashpoint is
gonna be known as something completely
different by the time the seasons done
because wait till you see what Barry
really did to the timeline it's gonna
blow your mind folks okay let's see as a
fan my mind was blown that's all I'm
gonna say
okay lead a billing says I hope you do a
legend legends of tomorrow episode I
hope so too a lot of cast in that man
you're juggling a lot I spend a lot of
plates in that instance and I
it'd be fun no I think hang a line I'd
do that in a heartbeat um let's see
Anthony James what DC her do you want to
see get their own show that hasn't
gotten one yet the question son the
question I don't care if it's Vic sage
or if it's renamed on Twitter the
question man you talking about a
featureless face just fightin crime
putting on the putty on the face
releasing the gas from the belt it
adheres and there he is no features and
whatnot mmm and if they do it let me get
a crack at it like Oh that'd be amazing
I love that character always have so I
think you'd fit very well in the CW
universe man so but there's only so many
hours that they can program right like
right now there's four superhero shows
and then when you add Riverdale that's
five comic book shows so I mean I don't
know I'll be amazing man the question
just keep raiding the DC toy box take
out every character raid that box RA ID
and to play with all of them man because
in the hands of any writer even a
character that you never like can become
something special okay David James
Herbert says thanks you very amazing art
keV thanks I don't know if it's amazing
but thank you for for even paying
attention
would I direct a DC Comics film
absolutely but I'm probably not the guy
and in fact I know this for a fact
because the phone never rings I'm
definitely not the guy that they think
of when they're like we got a you know
set the world on fire movies are about
visuals that you SiC amazing visuals
that you can put into a trailer that
make people want to believe their house
to pay to see that movie and I'm not
gifted like that I can't come up with
sick visuals that make you want to leave
your house they make you want to hide in
your house sometimes check out speaking
of which check out yo Gosar's now on
blu-ray and on itunes right this second
but I'm not the guy that comes up with
astounding art for you to look at and
stuff so that's why I like being on
these shows because the look is already
established they don't come to you going
like what are we gonna do man how should
this look you know what the show looks
like make it look like the flash make it
look like Supergirl so in that instance
all you're concentrating on is the
storytelling
aspect not the visual storytelling
aspect that's part of it as well but the
looks already been established with a
movie build out from scratch and was
something like the flash movie you gotta
create running man in the wake of the
running sequences that we've seen now in
both the x-men movies and the second
Avengers movie where we saw Quicksilver
so you know I'm not up to that to ask
you kidding me my characters barely walk
let alone run super fast but you know
who could do a great job we talked about
it Tim Miller so you know that's I'm
always geared for that
um if somebody even when they gave me
that job writing Superman years ago
Superman lives back in 96 when I sat
down one of brothers they were like
we're interested in you doing the past
on this I was like why wouldn't you you
reach out this is the exact thing I said
I swear to you never I'm so stupid I
never think about like looking after my
own future I said why wouldn't you hire
Mike Carlin the great Carlini himself he
was the editor of the Superman group at
that point or any number of the other
Superman writers who have like crushed
this character in comics and this was
1996 and this was the response well
those people work in comics you know
it's not really movies what a different
world we live in today so you know I was
I'm still geared that way even though we
live in a different world if somebody
writes you should like on Twitter I've
seen a lot of it like you should direct
the flash movie I shouldn't but my first
instinct is like they should get Tim
Miller I would love to watch Tim Miller
splash movie I've watched 10 Tim Miller
flash movies clearly he's proved himself
Deadshot he knows what he's doing with a
camera knows what he's doing with a
character so that's how I'm built and
then even if even if this fantasy world
where somebody says hey you know we want
you to ruin a movie for us I would
probably first put somebody else up for
the job you know know your limitations
and know your place in the universe and
right now my place is is not making big
movies for a studio particularly movies
that I want to go watch but on CW Man
where I can't screw it up because that's
you got to understand that cast and crew
makes an episode of flash every week
with or without my fat
the director is the only element that
changes all the time so you know for me
like uh I'm not like the visionary who
brought you two episodes of flash you
know I'm the guy who watched while these
very hardworking people brought you two
episodes of flash so you know I'm not
I'm not the guy to to create brand-new
running effects nobody's ever seen
I'd need Arman big-time I need Arman so
much that I'd be like Armand you better
direct the whole thing give it to Arman
this guy knows what to do and he's
directed episodes of the flash - okay if
you could direct write a flash story
into an episode what story would you
tell any story I'd bring my onomatopoeia
character to flash I mean it's not
really the same thing because he's
fighting a speedster an onomatopoeia
killed low-level vigilantes
you know it's non super-powered
individuals so he probably better off
over on arrow but since they're never
gonna call an arrow maybe I get to bring
the flash next season Andrew Todd Aaron
call me el bangs I'll be helping you out
okay let's see ever direct a horror TV
show asks Steve Cliff jr. I haven't but
out I would in a heartbeat
I've directed a horror movie couple of
them one was called Jersey girl but I'm
bummed let's see
animated Superman lives movie how about
it said dick taken hill Oh like based on
my script based on the Superman live
script I'd be tight dude I'm gonna lie
that'd be fun to see that's something I
worked on like 20 years ago at this
point so that'd be really amazing to
kind of see like they turn it into a
cartoon and get the people to do the
voices like cuz Nic Cage still around
and stuff and I wanted Michael Rooker
from my Lex Luthor so that'd be amazing
but you know I'm game that ain't up to
me kids that's up to the good folks at
Warner Brothers and stuff but if they
were ever to call and be like hey we
want to you know do your of cartoon
version of that Superman script you
wrote believe me I'd be like that'd be
that'd be dope man yeah you know you
closed all loops in life one way or
another
and that would be a nice way to close
that loop like oh we got to see what it
would look like
okay we're directing a sitcom appeal to
you asks Eric casino we're gonna find
out because I'm gonna go direct an
episode of the Goldbergs
over on ABC first week second week in
January I think it is thanks to Matt
Meyer the guy that I do talk salad and
scrambled eggs podcast all about Frasier
I do that with Matt we haven't done in a
few months people are very quick to
point out but but Matt works on that
show and he was like would you ever
direct an episode of this and I was like
yeah man that's that [ __ ] was funny and
so I'm gonna find out what it's like to
direct a sitcom I can't imagine what
that's like you know what I'm saying but
i but the Goldbergs are shot in such a
way where I'm like now that's my speed
so yeah I'm gonna find out what it's
like late in life I'm trying out a lot
of things man trying out direct and
episodic TVs trying to direct in
superheroes try and direct in sitcoms
next I'm trying out dudes
we'll see man who knows age 46 all rules
are out the window okay Daniel Denmark
says Lobo I agree completely that's why
I yell out when I climax Oh same thing
with that many exclamation marks as well
Michael C Park says that's right Michael
Rooker wasn't Clarke's clothes he was in
mall rats is mr. spending Brandis dad
okay do you relate to the Goldbergs in
your own life says Carlos rose Ali god
yes all right look I watched that show
and I go you can always tell something's
good when you're like why did not create
that like I should have created that
like that I feel like I created this
it's so close to my own life so that's
why it's gonna be very easy to slip into
Goldberg's world for me whenever I watch
that show I'm just like she made it I
should have made this this is it and
it's you know it's set in suburban
Pennsylvania like near Philly not too
far from where I grew up so and and me
and Adam grew up around the same time so
all of our references are the same so
every time I watch the show I'm like
it's like they incepted me like they
went in my head and took this show out
of my head I dig it so much so I look
forward to doing it okay but back to
flash well
we see more of Earth - Harrison wells
and Jessie quick asks Kiefer Davies yes
not in this episode tonight killer frost
but yes I think I can say that would be
with confidence even though I don't work
on the show regularly and probably by
spoiling that I just got kicked off the
show but I've heard things that yes okay
and what DC villain would you like to
bring to the CW TV universe asks Robert
Griffin hmm on flash they've done mirror
master but I wouldn't mind seeing the
mirror master that we all know from from
the comics with the outfit and the key
and stuff like that but they need the
gun
I don't know what you would call it but
Ian uses a key to to do his stuff in the
comics they've done a version of a
mirror master but I'd like to see that
one
let's see automatic peon I created that
villain so yeah I'd like to see
onomatopoeia on CW and I'd like to see
him done under me I don't think they can
do that makes I think might deal with DC
Comics at the time when I created out of
automate Appiah was they can't use it
unless I say yeah so a few times in the
comics I've gotten requests can we use
that character and this thing and tell
his origin I said no thank you I would
like to do that myself one day so I hope
I get to bring their character that'd be
amazing I'll do my flash that sounds
dirty that meant it I hope they let me
use that character on flash okay can I
knee says do we know who Savitt R is
without knowing that they are saboteur
oh you're trying to are you nuts it's so
early we're not even in December do you
really want to go down that rabbit hole
yeah just enjoy saboteur for a while
don't worry
what if anything is under that armour
let's let's just enjoy saboteur for the
moment and if you enjoy it give it up to
Armand man and this B effects crew that
takes a lot of time to do what they're
doing with that character he looks
really really badass but for the record
I know the secret
if you direct flash you just sit around
and ask questions that's the thing they
bring the ends director but wants them
inside the walls I'm all fans so I was
like what happens next then what happens
who's that what is this oh so I'm just
getting as a way to get information
early that's that's the secret to good
directing kids you're just there to pick
up information about shows that you like
let's see did I work Mike Dee ass Mike
Dee not that one but uh Mike T asked did
I work with Tobin Bell as he voiced
alchemy no they did that in Los Angeles
when we shot the episode in in Vancouver
but no but I've heard his voice in the
episode and it's badass man it's cool
very cool hearing him okay and and I
think let me see what are some of the
behind what are some behind-the-scenes
secrets from the flash sets that fans
might not know asks Kenna Thomas right
let's let's end with that well shall we
what are some stuff that folks may not
know well there were very long hard
hours to bring you a show that you love
everybody on that show cares about that
show
there's nobody I've worked on it twice
there's nobody it's like flash man like
whatever like yeah the boy runs fast
like everyone believes in this stuff
from the top all the way down to the
bottom whatever the bottom is whatever
the top may be they all care about the
material they love the story that
they're telling and they tell it well so
because of that that's that translates
that's why you like to show as much as
you do there's extra affection and in
every nook and cranny if you will but
what else can I tell you it's fun like
you know you can have a good time even
though the hours are long and stuff Kym
Myles
it was my DP directed Episode five with
the monster going through town and Kim
had this great idea on a day that was
really hard he brought in a bacon truck
and I was like that's a good idea I'm
gonna do that on my episode so at one
point in our longest day I think we
brought in a pay
in truck I paid for the bacon truck come
on everybody have bacon sandwiches and
stuff and they had a vegetarian option
if you're not into bacon and then at the
end of the episode I wrapped with I gave
out t-shirts I didn't get to do that my
first episode but everyone works so hard
on these shows like it's a movie and
when you wrap a movie everyone gets a
t-shirt and stuff that says I worked on
the movie so I've made t-shirts this
time around and and that was I don't
know it was fun it was really cool to
see people like I came out before the
show was over so like I took a lot of
pictures of people wearing that t-shirt
which was my old flash crest not the
reverse-flash crest but just the flash
normal flash crest I have but that was a
way to thank you for those counts
because after a runaway dinosaur like
you know a lot of people
yo Gosar's had come out its son in
Sundance in January and now it's on
iTunes today and blu-ray but from
January until May when the runaway
dinosaur aired like there are a lot of
people who didn't like yoga hosers and
just you know roasted my flesh and love
doing so going like oh this movie blows
and he sucks at his job and stuff like
that so runaway dinosaur was a godsend
because he'd like it proved oh he
doesn't necessarily suck at his job he
just doesn't care when he makes the
movies he makes he wants to make
whatever he makes and stuff and if
that's your goes are so big so it was
you know I got a lot of credit for that
runaway dinosaur so people going like oh
he is a director and stuff so you know
when I went back same people I worked
with to make killer killer frost
episodes same crew and cast
I want to thank him because you know
they gave me credibility like thanks to
runaway dinosaur and you know no person
is in charge of something by themselves
it takes a village as we say and and all
those folks made that episode and helped
you know kind of polish up my reputation
at a time when some people were like
trying to really push it down the toilet
so coming back you know the least I
could do is be like here and give him a
t-shirt you know because once again
killer frost people give me credit for
it too like why we did a great job and I
you know I I did the job that I did
everyone else who does that show week in
and week out they do they did the job
swatched and boy I loved watching creepy
little cuckold on set man where I'm just
like did you see what [ __ ] what kill the
flash just did
so flash killer frost just did then they
escort me off sex like he's even know
these characters names they did tell me
there's a won't here's a
behind-the-scenes story that I always
enjoy you know we were scouting on
Episode one they've run away dinosaur
and we were you know we're in a location
band going someplace and they were like
hey we're gonna stop for coffee and I
was like yeah as long it at jitters man
cuz I want to get me a cup of the flash
because they had just done like the
coffee they had to die dead in a Pepa
sewed where they introduced more the
coffee the jitters was called the flash
at a little lightning bolt in it and so
they were like man it's crazy like how
novel having someone directing the show
who actually watches the show and I was
like you mean all the directors don't
watch the show they're like sometimes
man we get directors on here don't even
know what the show is about and they
just told the story of one directors
name they withheld so I'm not even
withholding it I don't know the director
was man or woman but they got to set and
the director was like okay let's start
shooting bring out the flame and they
were like the flame and he meant the
flash like so I I don't ever I'd never
make that mistake I'm never on set going
like where's the flame at I love this
stuff and that's why if you like the
episodes I've done so far the only one
and tonight's episode has a lot to do
with just being a fan of material of in
the material as much as the people who
make this show every week love the
material so please tune in tonight man
killer frost episode of flash that's me
going very fast running fast position on
the CW thanks for hanging out here today
for the flash chat hope you learned some
new stuff and useful information and
let's kick back tonight I'm gonna be
live tweet in the episode so if you want
to follow that around on Twitter if you
got questions during the episode you
like deer fat ass I'm baffled why you
would dot I will be able to answer it
tonight
on Twitter during both airings the East
Coast airing and the
coasteering so thanks for hanging out
man flash tonight my name is Barry Allen
and I am the fast
you